i just actually interviewed your wife  elsa how cool is it that you both have  movies at the same time on netflix  it's very cool it's very cool she did  such an incredible job on that film and  it was great to see her you know do all  her press last week and the film be  number one and it was fantastic he was  so like supporting for me to do this  role so he was always like over here to  help you which was great to have him as  an executive producer because chris is  the the action man when you and elsa sit  down and you both have movies on netflix  what is it you decide to watch what's  your binge-worthy kind of  my film your film my film your film